Trascrizione: Serena Scodeller
Revisore: Anna Andreocci
Grazie.
Buonasera, sono veramente felice
di essere in questo contesto bellissimo
a sentire queste cose eccezionali.
Veramente, è bellissimo.
Allora, si scrive "scarto" si legge "tesoro".
La riflessione ispiratrice
che vorrei condividere
questo pomeriggio qua con voi,
ma che vorrei da domani nelle vostre case
permeasse anche un po'
la vostra quotidianità,
riguarda la convinzione,
oramai la quasi certezza,
che si possa costruire un'economia basata
sul recupero e sulla valorizzazione
degli scarti della produzione vegetale.
Quest'economia è un'economia basata
sulla conoscenza,
sull'applicazione delle scienze della vita
e permeata da tanta tanta etica.
Perché questa convinzione sempre più forte?
Perché...
Ci sono diversi punti.
Primo punto (primo dato di fatto):
esiste una classe di sostanze
studiata da anni oramai
in tantissime università,
in tanti centri di ricerca
sparsi per il mondo,
quindi che ha al suo attivo una mole
di letteratura scientifica accreditata
molto valida
che ha tutta una serie di effetti positivi,
documentati in questa letteratura,
ad esempio nella prevenzione
di alcune malattie vascolari,
nell'opporsi alla progressione
di certe forme tumorali
nella riduzione di effetti negativi
legati alla presenza del diabete
e di tutta una serie di patologie
che derivano da, passatemi l'espressione,
l'eccesso di fuoco amico;
nello spegnimento
di un eccesso di fuoco amico
che [si verifica]
quando i nostri sistemi di difesa,
troppo allertati, sempre troppo forse,
attenti in certe circostanze
a combattere i nemici,
a combattere quello
che deve essere combattuto,
perdono un attimo l'equilibrio
e cominciano a rivolgere il fuoco
anche contro i tessuti,
contro gli organi di cui fanno parte.
Ora, queste sostanze, vi rendete conto,
sono sostanze straordinarie,
cioè hanno delle proprietà
davvero eccezionali,
e altrettanto straordinari
sono i loro stabilimenti di produzione:
sperando che non abbiate
scarpe troppo eleganti
andiamo a visitare gli stabilimenti
di produzione di queste sostanze.
Gli stabilimenti di produzione
possono essere i vigneti
delle zone tra Asti,
l'Astigiano e Langa da cui provengo;
possono essere i vigneti bellissimi
che ci sono qua vicino a Verona
nella zona della Valpolicella,
o i vigneti dei colli piacentini
del prof. Delle Donne
e di tante altre parti
dell'Italia e del mondo.
Gli stabilimenti di produzione
di queste sostanze sono le vigne,
perché le sostanze di cui vi sto parlando
sono i polifenoli estratti dall'uva.
I polifenoli presenti nelle bucce
e nei semi dell'uva,
cioè i materiali che normalmente,
durante il processo di vinificazione,
verrebbero scartati,
o perlomeno sfruttati in scarsa parte.
Esistono tantissimi articoli,
esistono anche dei prodotti commerciali
a base di questi polifenoli.
Negli anni '90, nel '93 per la precisione,
sono apparsi
i primi prodotti per cosmetica,
in particolare creme
che servono a combattere
l'invecchiamento della pelle
contrastando lo stress ossidativo,
che hanno al loro interno questi polifenoli da uva
dallo scarto di lavorazione dell'uva.
E ci sono tanti prodotti a livello di nutraceutica
ma... ed è questo un secondo
punto fondamentale di riflessione,
grazie alla grande crescita
della conoscenza da una parte,
grazie alla crescita delle possibilità
tecnologiche e strumentali,
dei protocolli di ricerca
e di tutto quello che significa
test in vitro,
potenzialità applicative e strumentali,
noi nella nostra azienda
ci siamo fortemente convinti
che i tempi sono maturi
per promuovere queste sostanze
per farle arrivare a dei livelli tecnologici
molto più elevati.
A me piace molto questa fotografia
col grappolo di uva matura,
quindi durante il periodo della vendemmia,
nella mano che rappresenta la tradizione,
che rappresenta un qualcosa di antico
un rito molto antico delle nostre campagne
e mi piace pensare che questa mano
stia consegnando questo grappolo,
questa tradizione quindi,
l'antico stia consegnando questo grappolo
alla modernità delle colture cellulari,
vedete nelle due diapositive
alla vostra destra ci sono cellule fluorescenti,
quindi utilizzando
queste possibilità tecnologiche nuove,
queste possibilità analitiche
sempre più approfondite e complesse,
e che lo stia consegnando
per invitare a studiarlo,
per invitare ad andare oltre.
Quindi l'innovazione
che parte dalla tradizione
E qui capirete che, fatte queste premesse,
fa un certo quale effetto vedere
che simili biominiere,
passatemi l'espressione,
siano degli accumuli
di materiali potenzialmente preziosi
che potrebbero avere
delle applicazioni incredibili
sono per la maggior parte distrutti,
perché chiaramente le linee cosmetiche
che sono disponibili commercialmente
non utilizzano
una grande quantità di materiali;
la maggior parte di questi materiali
ancora oggi viene distrutta,
quindi vedere che un qualcosa
che potrebbe essere una splendida opportunità
in realtà è [vista come] un problema
e come tale è da gestire.
Quindi un problema
piuttosto che un'opportunità.
Introduco un ulteriore punto di riflessione:
io lavoro in un'azienda
che si occupa prevalentemente
di materiali da impianto
nel settore odontoiatrico,
ha molte sensazioni in comune
al racconto precedente,
nata tanti anni fa con tante difficoltà:
prima di poter vedere una luce positiva
da un punto di vista economico
abbiamo dovuto lavorare tanto,
però appunto con la passione,
con l'amore estremo per ciò che facevamo
siamo riusciti a sopravvivere
anche perché abbiamo sempre fatto
della ricerca di soluzioni,
di applicazioni, di protocolli,
di materiali, di processi innovativi
il filo conduttore della nostra esistenza.
Quindi,
negli ultimi due anni
ci siamo trovati a voler sviluppare,
abbiamo proprio desiderato e deciso che
un'attività importante doveva essere
lo sviluppo di un materiale
che serve per colmare difetti ossei,
per ripristinare delle situazioni ossee
a livello dentale
che sono un pochettino particolari,
un pochettino carenti:
ci sono dei difetti,
delle lacune, delle carenze
che, pensate, una volta potevano essere risolte
con dei prelievi di osso autologo
dalla sinfisi mentoniera della cresta iliaca,
quindi cose molto cruente.
Oggi ci sono a disposizione
dei materiali di natura varia,
possono essere sintetici
o di origine animale,
che vanno a compensare questi difetti;
quindi sono molto spesso
un importantissimo supporto per l'odontoiatra
che debba fare una terapia implantare,
in caso ad esempio di assenza di osso,
oppure di problemi e di difetti.
Allora, noi negli ultimi due anni
abbiamo lavorato allo sviluppo
di uno di questi materiali,
che voleva essere un materiale innovativo,
cioè non un qualcosa che semplicemente,
come potete intuire da quest'immagine,
viene messo lì come supporto,
quasi come sostegno meccanico
per compensare il difetto,
noi abbiamo voluto sviluppare qualcosa
di estremamanete innovativo
in cui il materiale inerte e le cellule
parlassero un linguaggio molto più simile,
parlassero la stessa lingua
e abbiamo fatto questo lavoro
in maniera proprio che
le cellule fossero attratte molto di più,
molto più rapidamente
e in maniera molto più efficiente
su questo materiale
e quindi più rapidamente
producessero tessuto osseo.
Mentre sviluppavamo
e portavamo a termine questo progetto
ci siamo imbattuti in un articolo di un autore
di un'università indiana
che diceva che somministrando polifenoli
dagli scarti di lavorazione dell'uva,
proprio testuali [parole],
e somministrandoli per via orale,
andava a verificare,
a valutare, ad apprezzare
anche un miglioramento notevole
a livello dei processi di rigenerazione ossea.
E allora, il pensiero laterale è stato:
ma perché,
anziché somministrarlo per via orale,
non possiamo questi polifenoli di uva
immobilizzarli nel nostro materiale
che va a sostituire,
a compensare il difetto osseo
e andarli quindi a rilasciare in sito,
là dove davvero servono?
E non esistono prodotti di questo tipo,
in questo momento.
Quindi fare diventare
un qualche cosa che
finora [è stato] utilizzato
a livello di cosmetica
o a livello di nutraceutica
un dispositivo medico vero e proprio.
E allora questo pensiero ovviamente
ci ha tolto qualsiasi dubbio, insomma,
e siamo andati alla ricerca
innanzitutto della materia prima
che in questo caso,
come vedete in questa diapositiva,
è un insieme di bucce macinate
da uva barbera,
ma si possono utilizzare
anche altri vitigni;
questa è una farina di bucce,
quindi un qualcosa che verrebbe eliminato
e poi c'è stato un lavoro
molto bello di estrazione,
di isolamento di queste molecole attive,
di questi polifenoli
da questa farina di bucce.
Vedete anche che bei colori hanno,
li abbiamo solubilizzati
con queste miscele acqua/alcool,
e infine abbiamo formulato diversi prodotti
che potevano essere in forma di polvere,
in forma di pasta
e abbiamo depositato la domanda di brevetto
per questo materiale.
Quindi, dalla tradizione più antica,
dalla tradizione delle nostre vigne
grazie al fatto di aver per un attimo
"invaso" un altro settore,
di aver attinto
al settore della nutraceutica,
ci si sono schiusi mondi
e abbiamo visto implicazioni
che prima non avevamo mai visto,
pur conoscendo
tutte le azioni benefiche dei polifenoli
e pur essendo immersi nelle vigne:
le vigne sono sempre state
il nostro orizzonte,
la camera bianca del nostro laboratorio
dà su una vigna bellissima
eppure non avevamo mai pensato
fino a quel momento
di combinare la tradizione
con l'innovazione in questa maniera.
E quindi questo per dirvi che
il materiale in questo momento
sta facendo inizialmente
tutti i test di laboratorio.
Abbiamo già verificato che comunque,
rispetto a qualsiasi materiale analogo,
non simile,
perché materiali di questa stessa tipologia
non ce ne sono sul mercato,
ma accanto a materiali che
hanno la stessa destinazione d'uso
ha una resistenza allo stress ossidativo
molto maggiore
e quindi ci sono tutte le premesse
perché questo prodotto
a breve veda la luce del mercato.
E non è solo un prodotto che vede
la luce del mercato, secondo me:
secondo noi è un modello
che deve prender piede,
che vedrà la luce della ribalta
perché è il modello del prodotto
che parte da uno scarto
e arriva, grazie ad applicazioni,
a tecniche, a conoscenze
ai livelli più elevati
della difficoltà dei materiali.
Non solo,
aver lavorato a questo progetto
ci ha convinto
che il modello deve essere anche esportato
ad altri settori,
che si può pensare a un'economia
anche in altri settori, pensiamo
ad esempio a quello tessile o tanti altri
e abbiamo creato un'associazione
che si chiama INNUVA
(l'acronimo funziona solo in inglese)
il cui logo sembra un grappolo viola,
sembra un grappolo d'uva,
in realtà è un grappolo
di cellule infiammatorie
che, durante uno dei test
in cui mettevamo le cellule
a contatto con questi polifenoli,
si sono aggregate in questa forma.
Per me è stato simbolico, insomma,
vedere questo grappolo di cellule
per un'associazione
che vuole promuovere l'utilizzo
(tra altre realtà industriali)
degli scarti della lavorazione dell'uva,
per fare prodotti
di elevato contenuto tecnologico.
Non solo, ma sapete che
ogni obbiettivo che si raggiunge
apre una porta che in realtà
ti porta in una stanza con tante altre porte,
noi pensiamo e siamo sicuri
anche dai dati
e dalla base di tutto quello
che c'è in letteratura
che lo stesso modello economico
che parte dal recupero degli scarti,
dai semi, dalle bucce dell'uva,
possa essere applicato
a tanti altri scarti vegetali.
Questa può essere
la produzione media
anche del pranzo di oggi,
ho visto a un certo punto, verso la fine,
che c'erano tanti piatti
che avevano queste bucce:
se noi le guardiamo con occhi normali,
con occhi, non senza cultura,
ma comunque indifferenti
da certi punti di vista,
è solo spazzatura,
è solo un problema, è solo quello
che le nostre amministrazioni comunali
chiamano "organico", "residuo organico".
Se noi abbiamo un po'
di cultura biomolecolare
sappiamo che lì dentro c'è un mondo
di molecole estremamente interessanti;
se a questa cultura biomolecolare
aggiungiamo gli occhi biotecnologici
sappiamo che è un insieme
di molecole interessanti
per creare, per realizzare
dei prodotti interessanti.
E se a tutto questo aggiungiamo
anche un po' di etica,
sappiamo che sono molecole interessanti
per realizzare prodotti eccezionali
di elevato contenuto tecnologico
per uno sviluppo sostenibile.
Grazie.